it's terrifying oh god what is he
shooting
[Music]
I can never go back home
not after what happened that day no no
it's just me and the beat snap that's
right
I'm a beet farmer at least beets can't
die except when I ate them I guess that
means they die but at least beets but at
least beets can't be an inanimate object
that speaks to me eh their feelings no
are you doing shut I've been spending my
time and my summer house away from
everyone that way I can't hurt nobody
I can't hurt nobody else
[Music]
there's something I need to tell you
I've been spending my time blocking
click clock click clock click clock and
rearranging flowers leap leap leap my
only friends are the sheeps stop stop
stop he was getting violence I had no
choice the beats are my only friends and
there will never be anyone else and I
plan to keep it that way
but Hagee what are you doing here fakie
you thought I needed a friend someone to
talk to see if I was all right
lies you were there that day why
is there a chicken here
excuse me water chicken someone needs to
be held responsible for what happened
and I know just the trick how to make
you talk follow me fate Hey fake Figgy
don't try and run away from me follow me
piggy yes I'll make you talk I'll make
you reveal who finally you're working
for I built this machine for the sheep's
but it can be modified that's right
get in the boat get in the boat
are you ready
that's right biggest could stop
any moment any moment fail you just tell
me who you're working for
don't force ain't you like it
it feels great like a back massage you
want me to increase that nut you're sick
wait is it actually
oh stop don't look at me don't look at
me fakie
nope you know what no follow me dumb
dumb you're dumb dumb now stay here and
when I get back I'm gonna find a new way
to deal with you okay I need to make
like a platform that can fly off on all
right gamers here we go
there's your guns here beautiful I need
to find another city ah here we go
perfect and perfect landing what are you
guys doing what are you guys doing to
that cactus
you're sick I'll take your bell off to
the next city
well my kippers like 20 times easier to
play now I know they like - oh god I'm
upside down what what they like that
will break oh god I'm flying faster than
it loads probably I need to be careful
but Jesus Christ I could just fly into a
mountain without Anoka Oh cut so there's
a new update with the bells in Minecraft
where you can use a redstone for them I
think I know just a way to make
talk perfect landing
- bells yes look
oh nice you got a little present
for me that's what I think about your
present know your place and understand
it what's that
that's okay you didn't want a child
anyway okay I see you hungry mmm I
made delicious beetroot soup oh it
tastes so good young mmm too bad
chickens don't eat beetroot oh you see
this raw chicken Figgy
so delicious oh I'm dying
Oh boohoo I don't complain about my life
and my problems what's that I need
to go to a doctor
I'm fine Figgy what's that your license
your license doctor and you can help me
cure me just drink this can of milk it
did nothing
you're a liar you're a liar and a
scoundrel
just admit it okay come here Figgy you
sleep outside tonight if the monsters
get you
not my problem when you're ready to talk
I'll be in there all right I see you
didn't decide to talk what is this what
is this what's that you baked me a
cake why is it poison because you love
me shut up take your stupid that's what
you're stupid I will have to go through
with a bail procedure
regardless so I think now that's
right that's right beat mr. beetroot you
can activate hell up I need a lever you
can activate bells with redstone
it works you like this Fang egg this can
go away at any moment just tell me
who you work or what
fine I will have to step up the
procedure you know what I really didn't
think it would come to this Figgy but
you leave me no other choice you
know we could have been friends you and
I didn't have to be like this okay so we
have a circle and then yes yes yes
[Music]
you're not annoyed you think it's this
policing sound shut up I'm not even done
yet I'm not even done yet yeah how
do you like that
[Music]
- it's better than what shut up
that's right Peggy you can have all the
beetroot in the world just tell me why
you're really here I know you're lying
what's that this song is popping it's
it's the new Alicia Keys no it is that
biggie I know it sounds similar you're
supposed to like this alright well thank
you I'm gonna go in my house now where I
have soundproof walls that's right I
won't be hearing anything once I close
his doors okay
so just call me when you need me
oh wow I can't hear anything
this is not annoying at all my god
why is this well so strong my god
I never seen someone so so resilient
none of my traps are working I must try
something even more nefarious very well
very well I am impressed and we
will have to move on to stage two you're
not gonna like stage two you're
not gonna like it
why are you torturing him Felix shut up
my throat
shut up he's just trying to be your
friend shut up Pete throat you don't
speak
dumbass be true okay I really want to
improve the house here this is my summer
house after all so while this noises are
terrorizing you and not me Oh what
is this a gift that's what I think about
your gift I want to try and make the
house a little prettier so we're gonna
do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
I did it I built the tallest tower in
Minecraft let's jump oh god am i flying
I am oh oh I messed that up but that's
awesome
Oh landed in the metal see that fakie
you will never land in the middle
goddamn goddamn biggie what other way
can i torture you
this is my new home goes all the way to
the top baby damn it's beautiful it's
perfect
unlike you figure you're nothing but a
failure got all the things I need my
beetroot soup and two beds so I don't
feel lonely yep this is the life I want
and I spawn outside the house all right
this time you what is this look at
me when I talk Annie Oh
you got me a flower Figgy I eat your
flower
what disgusting just like you are
you're pathetic
getting sick of this I'm gonna have to
use more desperate means of negotiation
there you go goddamn it's too
short what site it's okay you'll get it
next time
just try shut up yeah I will get
it next time
God you pissed me off baby there you go
there you go enjoy it enjoy it
while it lasts
what's that you're finally flying this
is a dream come true for you
dammit alright okay well what if we heat
up a little bit huh ya dumb baby
more like fakie what's that you like it
because your feet are cold
god dammit is there no breaking through
to you Peggy
alright well I'm gonna leave you cooking
there until I figure out what to do with
you
I figure are you ready to finally talk
oh my god what did you do this is
it I'm done
I didn't want to do this but I'm gonna
throw you off the tower you'll gladly
follow me anywhere it shut up shut up
just follow me okay of course he
knows that a climbing ladder
think he'd ruin my life I hate him oh my
god this is a very long time
there's no way around it Figgy just be
quiet and keep climbing I know you're
scared Figgy but this is it this is
goodbye it's been real too bad only one
of us has a parachute
bye what does it say
it says I love you oh god nah nah
oh god what have I done
he was my only friend wife Iggy wahey it
was like a father to me
wait a minute a faker can fly oh my
god
fuh he gay I'm so sorry Peggy will you
please forgive me I'm gonna fakie let's
go I made a mistake of thinking I
couldn't trust you you can sleep with me
tonight me cos I su casa
what's that fakie you want diamonds what
what a chicken use diamonds for whatever
ones figure she'll have from now
on
here you go anything for my best
bro in the world oh god no it was all
the truth Peggy why Peggy where you work
for what their sheep ah I should have
known
I'm sorry broke out he does a lot of
damage
please Maggie oh god be to save me my
god he's terrified oh god what is it
shooting Jesus it worked
yeah fake 64 raw chicken I'll
never forget you I never forget your
face oh god you know what I think it's
time it's time for me to and head back
home
[Music]
and back home the meatball never looks
so beautiful
Bengt
the Council of what their sheep
[Music]
must be overthrown
a new council will reign
hey Sven real cool right awesome
hope you guys enjoy this episode if you
did smash like check out the merch 100
million merch limited time now it's the
only time you're gonna get it and it's
you're gonna want this one see you guys
next time bye bye
[Music]